.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Katar -
Austragungsort der Fussball-WM.
Auch Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
tragen im reichen Wüstenstaat
zum reibungslosen Ablauf
des umstrittenen Turniers bei.
Einige von ihnen
leben schon lange hier.
Rund eine Flugstunde entfernt: Dubai,
offener und schillernder als Katar.
Ein Paradies für Fremde -
wenn man sich an die Regeln hält.
Wir begleiten
fünf Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
die sich auf das Abenteuer
am Golf eingelassen haben.
Worin liegt der Reiz? Was sind
die Herausforderungen des Alltags?
Fühlen sie sich trotz
des Kulturunterschieds heimisch?
Katar im Frühsommer 2022.
Die WM rückt näher.
Für Hotelier Chris Franzen bedeutet
das: rund um die Uhr Termine.
Heute hat
der Schweizer Botschafter eingeladen.
Wenn man in Zermatt aufwächst,
kann man sich nicht vorstellen,
in der weiten Welt zu sein
und jeden Tag mit Ambassadors,
Prime Ministers
und Presidents zu tun zu haben.
Momentan habe ich fast täglich
mit Ambassadors zu tun,
jetzt, da das Hotel öffnet.
Die WM in Katar
wirft ihre Schatten voraus.
Ein solches Turnier
mit Tausenden Fans aus aller Welt
will auch diplomatisch
begleitet sein.
You're okay?
- All good?
Good.
Botschafter Edgar Doerig
ist sich dessen bewusst.
Heute findet in Doha
die Gruppenauslosung statt.
Darum sind auch der Präsident des
Schweizerischen Fussballverbandes,
Dominique Blanc, und Nationaltrainer
Murat Yakin angereist.
Ja, für mich ist das
auch eine neue Erfahrung.
Es geht um Dienstleistungen,
die eine Botschaft
generell erbringt,
d.h.
konsularische Betreuung und Schutz.
Es kann zu Problemen kommen,
z.B. zu einem Passverlust.
Es kann aber vielleicht
auch die Möglichkeit geben,
dass jemand im angetrunkenen Zustand
Sachen macht,
die hier nicht unbedingt toleriert
sind, und da müssen wir bereit sein,
damit wir
diese Schweizer unterstützen können.
Ein grosses Thema
ist die Unterbringung der Fans.
Chris' Luxushotel
soll v.a. VIP-Gäste beherbergen.
Der Druck,
rechtzeitig fertig zu werden,
nimmt zu und Corona
erschwert die Planung nach wie vor.
Chris, erzähl, wie läuft's
mit dem Hotel? Geht es vorwärts?
Es fehlen mir immer noch
450 Angestellte ... Sorry, 430.
Okay.
Es gibt natürlich schon Challenges,
die man normalerweise nicht hat.
Es ist
momentan schon sehr spannend.
Wir hoffen doch,
dass wir die auch noch finden
in den nächsten
zwei bis drei Monaten.
Ab 1. Juni
fängt das intensive Training an,
wie für die
Fussball-Nationalmannschaft auch.
Wir haben unser Training
vor der Eröffnung im August.
Auch in einer Botschaft
ist der Besuch des Nationaltrainers
eine aussergewöhnliche Attraktion.
Chris hat einem gemeinsamen Bekannten
versprochen,
Murat Yakin Grüsse auszurichten -
und ein Selfie zu machen.
Voilà.
Als Kind war ich immer Fan
vom FC Liverpool.
In den 70er- und 80er-Jahren
war das  d i e  Mannschaft.
Natürlich bin ich als Walliser
Fan vom FC Sion
und seit den letzten zwei Jahren
auch vom FC Schaffhausen,
weil ein Kollege von mir und Murat
da involviert sind.
Ja, das sind die drei Mannschaften,
die ich verfolge.
Und natürlich
die Schweizer Nationalmannschaft.
Jetzt hoffen wir natürlich,
dass das klappt. Toi, toi, toi.
Wir haben Spieler,
die für Grosses gemacht sind.
Ja, wieso nicht als Überraschung
etwas Tolles bewirken?
* Klingeln *
Ich bin für das Fussballspielen
zuständig, und es ist klar,
dass vieles auch politisiert wird.
Wir können es nicht beeinflussen.
Wir haben Leute, die sich dafür
einsetzen, und so soll es auch sein.
Wir sind für die Teilnahme,
nicht für den Boykott.
Wir sind überzeugt, dass man
dank des Sports, dank des Fussballs,
grosse Fortschritte machen kann,
mit den Werten des Fussballs.
Und jetzt
haben wir noch ein kleines Geschenk.
Das ist das berühmte Trikot
der Nationalmannschaft ...
Super.
... mit Ihrem Namen.
Aber sie spielen erst im Dezember.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
- Also bitte.
Erst Mitte der 90er-Jahre startete
Katar seinen Modernisierungsprozess.
Seitdem versucht das Emirat
eine Gratwanderung
zwischen strukturellem Wachstum
und Bewahrung der Tradition.
Coralie Durussel geht mit ihren
Kindern oft in diesen privaten Park.
Hier kann die Westschweizerin
ohne Abaya hin.
Obwohl ihr Ehemann Saeed aus einer
alten, katarischen Familie stammt,
leben sie eine moderne Beziehung.
Doch wird ihre Tochter später die
gleichen Freiheiten geniessen können?
Go, go, go.
Ich bin Europäerin,
aber Aya ist Katari.
Ich bin gespannt, wie mein Mann
eines Tages reagieren wird,
wenn jemand fragt, warum
seine Tochter sich nicht bedeckt.
Wenn sie sich nicht bedecken möchte,
ist das natürlich ihre Entscheidung.
Eins weiss ich: Er wird meiner
Tochter immer die Wahl lassen.
Zwei Kulturen unter einem Dach:
Was oft in einem Kompromiss mündet,
kann das Leben auch bereichern.
Saeeds erster Besuch in Denezy/VD,
dem Wohnort von Coralies Vaters,
war ein
unvergessliches Familienabenteuer.
Es war toll.
Mein Vater hat
Abdulrahman zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Wegen Covid ging es ja vorher nicht.
Das ist ein typisches Bild.
Wäre ich in der Schweiz geblieben,
hätte ich sicher ein ganz anderes
Leben geführt: ich auf dem Traktor.
Natürlich mit meinem Sohn.
Das sind tolle Erinnerungen.
Schau, hier ist er
zum ersten Mal auf einem Pferd.
I loved it.
Es war grossartig. Besonders, meinen
Sohn in dieser Natur zu sehen.
Das Wetter
war natürlich ganz anders als hier.
Das Grün, die Kühe - wunderschön.
Ich habe es richtig genossen.
Ganz überzusiedeln,
kommt für Saeed aber nicht infrage.
Wir haben unsere Jobs hier.
Wir geniessen viele Vorteile,
haben Land hier.
Das würde ich im Moment
nicht aufgeben.
Vielleicht im Ruhestand.
* Sanfte Musik *
Die Geschäftsfrau Andrea Hirschi
führt in Dubai
ein typisches Expat-Leben auf Zeit.
Dazu gehört auch das Ausprobieren
von hiesigen Freizeitaktivitäten.
Fahre nicht ganz so schnell, bitte.
- Du fährst 50 km/h oder so.
Dune Bashing nennt sich
ein beliebter Offroad-Spass.
Da solche Wüstenausflüge
mit dem Auto nicht ungefährlich sind,
nehmen meist mehrere Fahrzeuge teil.
Ausser Andreas Mann Remo
ist noch eine befreundete Familie
aus Schweden dabei.
Jetzt lassen wir Luft raus.
Gerade so viel,
dass wir in der Düne fahren können
und nicht stecken bleiben.
Und wenn ich zu viel Luft ablasse,
ist es kein Problem.
Ich habe einen Kompressor
und kann wieder Luft reinlassen.
Fahren auf Sand erfordert Übung.
Hinzu kommt:
Es hat in den letzten Tagen geregnet.
Ja, nasser Sand.
Man muss sich
ziemlich konzentrieren.
Langsam!
- Ja.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Oh!
Hoppla!
Uh!
Schwierig. Wir haben
schon ein paar Autos gesehen -
Autoruinen,
die stecken geblieben sind
und auf dem Dach liegen
oder schlimmer.
Andrea hat eher Mühe
mit solchen Luxusabenteuern,
aber Remo ist offroad-erfahren -
und findet es lustig.
Nein, Angst eigentlich nicht.
Das ist alles im sicheren Bereich,
was wir machen.
Es ist gut.
So kommt sie aus ihrer Komfortzone.
Scheisse!
Ganz langsam! Langsam, langsam,
langsam, langsam, langsam, langsam!
Mehr rechts.
Voll rechts, langsam ...
Langsam, langsam ...
Die Challenge beim Dune Bashing ist,
wie ein Surfer
am Kamm der Düne entlangzugleiten.
Wenn es nach Andrea ginge,
müsste das wohl nicht unbedingt sein.
Ja!
Uh!
Nicht so schnell, ich habe Schiss.
- Du musst keine Angst haben.
Sonst müssen wir
noch die Autos tauschen.
Nach dem kleinen Crashkurs
zeigt Andrea, was sie gelernt hat.
Für das Fahrvergnügen im Sand
haben sie extra eine Vorrichtung
einbauen lassen, die verhindert,
dass das ABS blockiert.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Juhu.
Yes, I did it.
Auch wenn es
nicht immer den Anschein macht:
Das Thema Umweltschutz
ist auch in Dubai angekommen.
Matteo Boffa schreibt mit nach-
haltigen Start-ups eine Erfolgsstory.
Heute soll er an der
Swiss International Scientific School
aus seinem Leben erzählen.
Thank you. Wow, that's beautiful.
Hallo?
Matteos Mission:
jungen Menschen zu zeigen,
dass Nachhaltigkeit
nicht nur sinnvoll ist,
sondern auch ein gutes Geschäft.
Die Teenager
machen hier einen Bachelor,
meist als Vorbereitung
für ein Studium im Ausland.
Die Swiss
International Scientific School
ist die grösste Schweizer Schule
ausserhalb der Schweiz.
Einen Unternehmer
wie Matteo zu Gast zu haben,
gibt den Schülern einen Einblick
in die Geschäftswelt -
und die Chance, ein paar
praktische Erfahrungen zu sammeln.
Matteos beste Geschäftsidee
hatte ein junger Mann,
damals kaum älter
als diese Schüler/-innen.
Keep it up. I'm open
for any questions or suggestions.
And thank you for listening to me.
Bis zu 26'000 Fr. pro Jahr
investieren die Eltern
hier in die Zukunft ihrer Kinder.
Ein Netzwerker wie Matteo
kann da später nützlich sein.
Wenn nur 1 % dieser jungen Menschen
später ein Start-up
im Bereich Nachhaltigkeit,
Soziales oder Umwelt gründet,
wäre das für mich
schon ein grosser Erfolg.
Es ist nicht nötig,
dass es alle machen.
Das wäre auch nicht realistisch.
Aber eine Person kann
einen grossen Unterschied machen
und so wiederum eine Wirkung
auf andere Menschen haben.
Daher wäre 1 % für mich
schon ein grosser Erfolg.
Die Schweiz gehört
zu Dubais Top-5-Handelspartnern.
Gewinnchancen verspricht alles,
was mit digitaler Entwicklung
und Nachhaltigkeit zu tun hat.
Nach der Wirtschaftskrise 2009 stehen
alle Zeichen wieder auf Wachstum.
Mitgetragen wird dieser
von den rund 3 Mio. Ausländern,
die im Emirat leben und arbeiten.
Expats aus Europa,
die für ein paar Jahre herkommen,
führen meist
ein privilegiertes Leben.
Einzig die grosse Sommerhitze
macht allen zu schaffen.
* Der Hund winselt. *
Ja, wir gehen rein.
Doch Dubai wäre nicht Dubai,
hätte es nicht auch
für dieses Problem eine Lösung:
den wohl grössten
Hunde-Indoor-Spielplatz der Welt.
Honey, warte, warte, warte.
Und go! Hopp.
Rund 60 Fr. zahlt man hier pro Tag,
Hol- und Bringservice inbegriffen.
Dafür können sich Cooper und Honey
auf diversen Innen- und Aussenflächen
austoben,
einem Areal,
so gross wie 18 Tennisplätze.
Los! Der Ball.
Wo ist er?
Der Indoor-Spielplatz
ist wichtig hier,
weil die Hunde in Dubai
fast nirgendwo hindürfen.
Und auch die Hitze. Jetzt
haben wir wieder 38 °C draussen.
Es ist einfach zu heiss.
Wir gehen morgens kurz raus,
aber wenn es im Sommer so heiss ist,
gehen wir in den Hundepark, indoor.
Hier können sie auch
mit anderen Hunden spielen.
Ja, es ist doch toll.
Es ist wie ein Kindergarten
für Hund und Herrchen.
Und hier drinnen
übernachten die Hunde.
Es gibt überall so Zimmer,
wo sie übernachten können.
Hier gibt es sogar
eine Suite für ganze Hundefamilien.
* Bellen, fröhliche Musik *
Ein Freizeitpark nur für Hunde.
Doch bei allen Superlativen:
Am Ende ist so ein Kunstrasen
eben doch nur ... künstlich.
Ja, es ist ein Kompromiss.
Du kannst einen Wald nicht ersetzen.
Du kannst die Natur, die wir in
der Schweiz haben, nicht ersetzen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall da, um
das Hundeleben hier gut zu machen.
Rein.
Zurück in Katar.
Mit der Ausrichtung der Fussball-WM
erneuert das Emirat auch gleich
die gesamte Infrastruktur.
Good evening. How are you?
An diesem Abend findet in Doha
die Gruppenauslosung statt.
You're okay?
All okay? Good. Thank you.
Hello. Hi.
- Hi.
Auf der Gästeliste: Chris und
seine australische Ehefrau Rachel.
Die Schweizer Botschaft
hat Freunde und Businesspartner
zum Public Viewing eingeladen.
Während das Turnier im Westen
kritisch gesehen wird,
wächst die Vorfreude in Katar
mit jedem Tag.
Also, es ist natürlich schon so:
Auch als Hotelier
ist man eingebunden.
Es herrscht schon
ein Teamspirit hier.
Man ist doch Teil
dieses ganzen Projekts Katar 2022.
Die Faszination ist schon da, und
die Energie steigt mit jedem Tag.
Man merkt das.
Es ist wirklich super.
Lothar Matthäus. Lothar.
- Komm jetzt!
Chris ist ein Fussballfan,
jedoch kein Fussballverrückter.
Als wir im Oman wohnten,
kam Australien
für ein Spiel gegen den Oman.
Ich habe das Spiel
mit den Kindern gesehen.
Er wollte nicht,
weil es zu heiss war.
Einfache Gegner wären schön,
doch das Los verteilt
an diesem Abend keine Geschenke.
Cameroon.
- Yes.
Serbien, Kamerun und Brasilien.
Das ist natürlich eine Topgruppe,
keine Frage.
Es wird nicht einfach.
Aber der Weg ins Finale
war noch nie einfach.
Schauen wir, was passiert.
Katar
wird wegen der Arbeitsbedingungen
auf den WM-Baustellen
immer noch stark kritisiert.
Rita Schiavi und
das internationale Gewerkschaftsteam
haben durch Inspektionen und
Gespräche jedoch einiges bewirkt.
Für heute hat die internationale
Bau- und Holz-Gewerkschaft BHI
mit der Fussballgewerkschaft FIFPro
ein Fussballturnier
für die Arbeiter und Arbeiterinnen
organisiert.
Das Spezielle an Katar ist:
Wir machten ja schon früher
solche Kampagnen in Südafrika,
Brasilien und Russland, aber dort
gab es Gewerkschaften vor Ort.
Doch hier in Katar,
wo es keine Gewerkschaften gibt,
haben wir von der Internationalen
aus Gewerkschaftsarbeit gemacht.
Darum sind wir da eben auch selber
vor Ort, machen die Inspektionen
und treffen die Leute,
und das ist das Spezielle.
Das ist nicht irgendwas Abstraktes,
sondern die Leute erzählen uns,
welche Probleme sie haben.
Das sind jetzt die Menschen,
um die es geht.
* Anpfiff *
Das Turnier ist der Abschluss
einer zweitägigen Konferenz,
auf der mit dem Arbeitsministerium
über weitere Schritte
diskutiert wurde.
Dass sich sogar Ex-Profis
wie Damiano Tommasi engagieren,
hat mehrere Gründe.
Goal!
* Jubel *
Es geht nicht allen Fussballern gut,
es verdienen nicht alle Millionen.
Was noch hinzukommt:
Viele Väter der Fussballer
waren Bauarbeiter.
Z.B. auch des Australiers Simon.
Er ist italienischstämmig und sein
Vater war in Australien Bauarbeiter.
Er wurde Profifussballer.
Und das finde ich
einen schönen Zusammenhang,
den man bei uns
in der Schweiz gar nicht so sieht.
Wichtig auch: Von den Verbesserungen,
welche die BHI in Katar bewirkt hat,
profitieren nicht nur die Bauarbeiter
auf den WM-Baustellen.
Man kann eigentlich sagen,
dass fast alle grossen Baufirmen
heute diese Standards haben
und sie anwenden.
Sie werden sie wohl in
andere Länder im Golf exportieren.
Es geht um mehr
als nur die 40'000 Leute,
die auf den Stadionbaustellen
gearbeitet haben.
Aber es gilt noch nicht für alle,
und es gibt sehr vulnerable Gruppen.
Für sie ist es überall auf der Welt
sehr schwierig,
z.B. für die Hausangestellten.
Es ist ganz schwierig,
diese Gruppe zu schützen.
Aber wir
werden auch da noch weitermachen.
Und ich bin überzeugt,
dass wir auch da
mit der Zeit was erreichen.
Seit 2018 kämpft
die internationale Gewerkschaft BHI
für eine Verbesserung
der hiesigen Arbeitsbedingungen.
Ritas Mann Hans begleitet seine Frau
zum ersten Mal nach Doha -
als neutraler Beobachter.
Er kennt das zähe Ringen um
jeden Zentimeter für die gute Sache.
Ja, ich finde es schon gut,
was sie macht, weil ...
Ich glaube schon,
dass diese Arbeit
nicht von allen gewürdigt wird -
gerade von jenen, die Vorurteile
haben, was Katar betrifft.
Und die staunen dann eigentlich,
dass Rita schon dreimal
in Katar gewesen ist.
Aber ich glaube schon, dass
das BWI da einiges erreicht hat.
Noch am Tag dieses Turniers
äussert sich Amnesty International
erneut über die Situation
der Migrationsarbeiter in Katar.
Diese sei - trotz der Reformen -
nach wie vor kritisch.
Also, es ist klar, das ist gut.
Amnesty und andere Organisationen
haben mitgeholfen, Druck zu machen.
Und diesen Druck braucht es.
Immer noch.
Aber man muss schon sehen:
Wir haben einen wichtigen
Zwischenschritt erreicht.
Wir haben viel erreicht,
aber natürlich noch nicht alles.
Das ist ganz klar,
und wir werden weitermachen.
Wir werden weiterkämpfen
für das Workers' Center.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Leute
einen sicheren Ort haben,
wo ihnen geholfen wird.
Das gibt es noch nicht.
Wir werden da aktiv bleiben.
Wir lassen die Leute nicht im Stich.
Wie nachhaltig die Reformen
auch über die WM hinaus sind,
muss sich erst noch zeigen.
Im Hauptquartier
des Supreme Committee
bereitet sich Coralie
auf einen besonderen Termin vor.
In einer Ausstellung bringt sie -
meist ausländischen Diplomaten -
die Fussballtradition
ihrer zweiten Heimat näher.
Heute begrüsst sie Rita.
Die PR-Expertin
und die Gewerkschafterin
treffen sich zum ersten Mal.
Bis 1971
war Katar britisches Protektorat.
Coralie geht in ihrer Rolle auf:
Der Tag der WM-Vergabe
war für das ganze Land ein Feiertag.
Als ich an diesem 2. Dezember in
der Fanzone stand und Zeugin wurde,
wie Katar - damals wahrscheinlich
das kleinste Land auf der Karte -
die Ausrichtung der WM gewann,
dem grössten Sportereignis,
da war ich stolz.
Als ich 1991 nach Katar kam,
war hier Wüste.
Meine Kinder sind Katari.
Eines Tages werden sie in einem
der Stadien sitzen und sagen können:
"Mama hat mitgeholfen,
das zu bauen."
"Mama war ein Teil davon."
Das ist toll und eine Ehre.
50 km ausserhalb von Doha:
eine Hightech-Milchfarm
mitten in der Wüste.
2017 belegten die Nachbarstaaten
Katar mit einem Embargo.
Der Vorwurf: Das Emirat unterstütze
radikalislamische Gruppen.
Lebensmittel wurden rationiert.
Seitdem setzt Katar verstärkt
auf Selbstversorgung.
Ah, schau, wir sind da: Baladna.
Da ist ja links und rechts
wirklich nichts.
Gott, guck mal die
grossen Air-Conditioning-Units da.
Die sind wahrscheinlich
für die ganzen Stallungen.
Chris interessiert sich
für eine Zusammenarbeit.
Über 400'000 l Frischmilch
werden hier täglich verarbeitet,
und der Bedarf
wird während der WM noch steigen.
CEO Piet Hilarides nimmt sich Zeit
für einen Rundgang.
Wow!
Für das Know-how holte man sich
Experten aus dem Land der Cowboys ...
Okay.
Ja, eben, wie er gesagt hat,
die ersten Kühe wurden importiert.
Und jetzt haben die schon Kühe,
die hier geboren sind.
Also, das ist schon ...
Wow, eindrücklich.
Weideland sucht man in der Wüste
vergebens. Die Kühe stehen auf Sand.
Kühlsysteme sorgen in den Stallungen
für konstante 24 °C.
Für den Nachwuchs
sorgt man mit künstlicher Besamung.
Alle 30 Min. kommt ein Kalb zur Welt.
Es ist natürlich schon so:
Die Kuhhaltung in der Wüste
ist ja nichts Natürliches.
Jede Kuh wäre lieber
auf der Stafelalp in Zermatt
als hier in der Wüste in Katar.
Man muss aber verstehen,
dass das eine Notwendigkeit
für das Land ist,
damit es selber genug Milchprodukte
produzieren kann.
Aber wir haben natürlich
die Vorstellung als Schweizer:
Es gibt die Bergkühe auf der Alp,
die gemolken werden müssen.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich heute
in der Schweiz auch nicht mehr so.
Da müsste ich mich
selber mal schlaumachen,
wenn ich das nächste Mal
wieder zu Hause bin.
Im Besucherpavillon
des Supreme Committee
tauschen sich
Coralie und Rita weiter aus.
Das Thema wie so oft: die Zustände
auf den Stadionbaustellen.
Die Arbeiter,
speziell die Bauarbeiter,
arbeiteten wirklich
unter schlechten Bedingungen,
als wir hier vor zehn Jahren
unsere Arbeit begannen.
Aber es gab Verbesserungen,
und - wie du richtig sagst -
in der Schweiz gab es in
den 1960er-Jahren die Saisonniers.
Die waren
in einer ganz ähnlichen Situation.
Natürlich
kann man noch einiges verbessern,
aber das ist überall
auf der Welt so.
Dieser ständige Fokus,
die negative Presse, das nervt,
weil wir viele gute Dinge machen,
über die niemand berichtet.
Rita
hat sicher ein offenes Ohr dafür.
Aber, ganz ehrlich,
mich persönlich regt das auf -
weil Doha mein Zuhause ist
und Katar meine Heimat.
Auch in der Schweiz gäbe es Sachen,
die man kritisieren könnte,
findet die gebürtige Westschweizerin.
Das versteht Rita als Kind
italienischer Einwanderer gut.
Zwei Frauen, die den Modernisierungs-
prozess in Katar mitgestalten.
Jede auf ihre Art.
Zurück in Dubai: Andrea hat
einen wichtigen Termin auf dem Amt.
Die gelernte Coiffeuse und Geschäfts-
frau möchte gerne eine Lizenz.
Ich würde gerne
als Freelancerin arbeiten
und für das
muss ich eine Bewilligung haben.
Ich habe da schon angerufen,
aber sie wollten mir am Telefon
keine Auskunft geben und meinten,
ich solle vorbeikommen und ...
Ja, das machen wir jetzt.
Dass Frauen Geschäfte machen,
ist in Dubai mittlerweile Standard.
Trotzdem kann es nicht schaden,
ein bisschen aufs Image zu achten.
Besser die Jacke anziehen,
damit man die Tattoos nicht sieht.
Dann sehe ich etwas seriöser aus.
Erster Eindruck: Das Amt
ist eher eine moderne Café-Lounge.
Hello, good morning.
Thank you. Hi. Good morning.
Okay.
Doch ganz so einfach ist es nicht:
Die digitale ID hat ihre Tücken.
Die Gesichtserkennung
lässt Andrea nicht ins System.
Es geht einfach nicht. Und jetzt
muss ich es am Kiosk updaten.
Aber ich weiss noch nicht genau,
was. Das passiert hier immer.
Nachher weiss man nicht,
was man tun soll.
Aber man kann anscheinend hinlaufen.
Der Kiosk ist
eine kleine Zweigstelle der Behörde,
gleich nebenan.
Hi.
Die nächste Hürde:
Um ihre ID upzudaten, braucht Andrea
die Hilfe ihres Mannes.
Hi, this is Andrea calling.
Ja. Remo?
Die brauchen deine OTB-Nummer,
weil deine ...
Dieses OTB, was sie dir schickt.
- Das ist 12569.
It's okay?
- Yes. Thank you.
God!
- Yes, thank God.
Okay, perfect.
Thank you. Have a good day. Bye.
Bye.
Aus altem Müll neue Werte schaffen.
In allem, was mit Upcycling zu tun
hat, scheint Matteo mitzumischen.
Mit einer App, bei der er involviert
war, wird Recycling zum Spiel:
Flaschen sammeln - Punkte sammeln.
In Zukunft wird man die Punkte
in eine Kryptowährung
umtauschen können.
Deswegen
ist es ein spassiges System,
das auch junge Menschen motiviert,
Plastikflaschen zu sammeln
und ordnungsgemäss zu entsorgen.
Die Entwicklung oder der Import
von Recyclingsystemen aus Europa
nach Dubai ist ein gutes Business.
Flaschen entsorgt, Punkte gesammelt.
Nun können Megan und Matteo
den Abend vorbereiten.
Das Paar hat Freunde
zum Käsefondue eingeladen,
stilecht mit Schweizer Deko
und "richtigem" Käse.
Leider findet man in Dubai
keinen Schweizer Käse.
Daher bringe ich jedes Mal,
wenn ich aus dem Tessin zurückkomme,
diesen Supermarktkäse mit.
Der kommt aus meiner Region,
aus einer Käserei am Gotthard.
Auch nach sechs Jahren Dubai
hält Matteo an
gewissen Schweizer Eigenarten fest.
Eine Sache,
die mir an Matteo auffällt, ist,
wie genau er es mit der Zeit nimmt.
Er ist überpünktlich.
Gibt es ein Meeting um 18 Uhr,
muss er schon 5 Min. vorher da sein.
Das ist wohl sehr schweizerisch.
Es ist kein Problem.
Ich bin zwar ganz anders,
also muss ich mich da
auch ein bisschen anpassen.
Aber ehrlich gesagt
finde ich es gar nicht schlecht,
die Dinge so zu machen wie er.
Andrea ist ihrer Arbeitserlaubnis
einen grossen Schritt nähergekommen.
Great.
- So it's with my e-mail address?
Spannend ist es gerade.
Ähm ... Man muss sich registrieren.
Was genau, weiss ich selber nicht,
aber wie es aussieht,
bis jetzt,
läuft's wie am Schnürchen.
Leider ist auch der Bezahlvorgang
nicht ohne Remo möglich.
Also, im Einkaufszentrum
kann ich ohne Code einkaufen,
aber sobald es andere Sachen sind,
brauche ich immer den Code von ihm,
und das ist mühsam.
Das nervt mich.
Die geduldige Sachbearbeiterin
findet schliesslich eine Lösung:
Andrea kann den Bezahlvorgang später
von zu Hause aus abschliessen.
Ihren Plänen
steht nichts mehr im Weg.
Ich habe es
fast nicht mehr geglaubt.
Ich habe schon schwarzgesehen.
Ich hätte es nicht geglaubt.
Und ich freue mich jetzt.
Jetzt kann ich offiziell daheim
Kunden bedienen.
Dubai hat sich zum Hotspot
für Kurztrips aus Europa entwickelt.
Matteo empfängt zwei alte Freunde
aus dem Tessin: Walter und Brian.
Die beiden sind ziemlich beindruckt
von Matteos Freizeitsport-Trophäen.
Wenn ich ehrlich bin, ist der
grosse Vorteil unserer Freundschaft,
dass es jedes Mal,
wenn wir uns sehen, so ist,
als wären wir nie getrennt gewesen.
Selbst dann, wenn ich Monate
oder sogar ein Jahr
nicht in der Schweiz war.
Mit Freundin Julia
ist die Runde komplett.
Noch immer trauern alle
der wegen Covid abgesagten
grossen Hochzeitsfeier nach.
Zum Trost kann man sich ja zumindest
Matteos romantischen Unterwasser-
Heiratsantrag nochmals anschauen.
Als Matteo
im Winter 2016 nach Dubai ging,
kam dies für seine besten Freunde
wie aus heiterem Himmel,
obwohl sie wussten,
dass es ihm schlecht ging:
Seine erste Ehe
war in Brücke gegangen.
Bereits ein Jahr zuvor
war seine Mutter gestorben.
Was als Flucht begann, wurde zum
Anfang eines komplett neuen Lebens.
Ganz am Anfang
habe ich natürlich gedacht:
"Unter all den Orten: Dubai?"
"Nein, warum gehst du
ausgerechnet nach Dubai?"
Aber natürlich ist es auch
eine Herausforderung,
eine sehr spannende Challenge,
wie man auf Englisch sagen würde.
Das ist ein Land
mit einer ganz anderen Kultur,
einer ganz anderen Denkweise als
die Schweiz, die wir ja alle kennen.
Und so muss ich auch sagen,
dass ich fast stolz auf ihn war.
Ich glaube,
ich hätte es wohl genauso gemacht.
Matteo
hat sein Glück in Dubai gefunden.
Und damit auch ein neues Zuhause ...
Es klingt vielleicht wie
ein Klischee, aber für mich gilt:
Zu Hause ist, wo das Herz ist.
In Dubai Fondue zu essen,
war für mich noch vor sieben,
acht oder zehn Jahren unvorstellbar.
Und nun bin ich hier
mit meiner Frau aus Südafrika,
die ich in Dubai getroffen habe,
zusammen
mit meinen besten Kindheitsfreunden
und einer gemeinsamen Freundin,
die wir hier kennengelernt haben.
Das zeigt, dass man sich
eine schöne Umgebung schaffen kann,
wenn man bereit ist, Türen,
aber v.a. sein Herz zu öffnen.
In der letzten Folge: Geschäftsfrau
Andrea hat es geschafft:
die Lizenz in der Tasche,
die erste Kundin auf dem Stuhl.
Ausserdem: Coralie und Saeed
planen ihre Zukunft in Katar.
Doch der Bau ihres Hauses
geht schleppend voran.
Und: Chris Franzen unter Druck. Wird
sein Luxushotel rechtzeitig fertig?
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022